we are happy to have let's talk today
about degree restricted random processes
which are far from uniform or maybe not
who knows
thank you very much thanks for the
organization putting together this nice
workshop and for giving the chance to
speak here so everything I'm going to
talk about today is joint work with Mike
Malloy and my PhD student Ellen Sawyer
and the basic idea is I'll show you what
I think is the simplest possible way to
generate the graph with a given degree
sequence and then we can ask the
Strategic question what can we say about
the distribution of this graph is the
distribution of this graph like close to
uniform or not okay so to put this maybe
a little bit into context
let's maybe just focus first on the case
of
um Regular graph sequences okay and so
suppose you give an undergraduate
student a task to generate something
like a random D regular graph they are
most likely not come up with the
configuration model or something like
this which is kind of fine-tuned to
generate the uniform distribution but
most likely they'll come up with I think
the following a random gritty approach
so you start off with an empty graph and
vertices and then use a step by step try
to add as many edges to your graph as
possible without violating this maximum
degree constraint okay so in each step
add a new Edge which does not violate
the maximum degree D constraint
and this is such a natural algorithm
that was study already in the 1980s if
you go back to the mathematical
chemistry literature it was suggested
there as
a model and in the early 90s romantic
showed that actually for fixed this
graph in some sense
um is this process is good in the sense
that it actually finishes with a
deregular graph unless there's some
parity constraint which prevents you
from doing that so in that sense this is
a graph a process which generates a
deregular graph but the question now is
what can we say about the distribution
in particular is it similar to
um a uniform random D regular graph or
not
and
um formal conjectured in the late 1990s
that for this deregular case it actually
should be similar to a deregular graph
and the notion of similarity uses
contiguity okay
and what I want to discuss in this talk
is kind of a a variant because look in
this process we just say every vertex
should have degree at most D but of
course when we think about degree
sequences we can just say every vertex
VI can have a degree at most d i and
then we can ask the same question
and what we can show is that if the
degree sequence is not quite regular
there's some irregularities then we can
actually show that these things are
different different and quite a
substantial way that'll be the main
result I want to talk about
let's just be sure that we're all on the
same page how this this process looks
like so here's a small degree sequence
so we have three vertices of the V2 two
of three three
and now what we do is we step by step
add these edges to the graph
so we don't allow here for Loops or
multiple edges
and the thing I want to just illustrate
here is what happens at some point that
at some point this degree constraints
will be satisfied so this vertex has to
be two and then the way to think about
it is this vertex becomes inactive it no
longer plays a role because you can
never ever connect a Vertex here to this
guy okay so this kind of shows that
already the set of vertices to which I
can actually add edges
kind of changes over time
so we run this process until the end and
then we want to understand what is the
distribution we get at the end as I
already told you there's this result by
One Direction ski which actually works
for all degrees which have say bounded
maximum degree so the maximum degree is
a constant then what they proved is
again that it actually said it actually
works in the sense that in the end every
vertex V I will have degree d i if your
degree sequence is graphic meaning that
you actually can generate such a graph
foreign
so now to rephrase this question is how
similar is now the output of this degree
restricted process to a uniform random
graph with a given degree sequence and
depending on which hat you want to put
on you can ask this question in many
different ways but these are essentially
all the same way so you can ask okay is
there a way can I actually distinguish
them okay can I do it algorithmically
um if you have a model statistics
perspective if you ask maybe more from
common tutorial probability you're
probably interested in what can you say
about the typical properties are these
graphs kind of the same with respect to
typical properties which leads to this
notion of contiguity which says that any
graph property it holds with one model
was probably tending to one will also
holding the other model with probability
10 into one
if you're more interested maybe in
algorithms for actually generating
um for example approximately regular
graphs
then you can also ask well does this
process work in a sense that it actually
gives me something that's close to
uniform which would be kind of nice
because admittedly this is kind of the
easiest way you might think of
generating such a such a model and it's
quite also efficient to implement
similarly maybe if you ask a strategic
question for modeling you know in
physics there's this principle we want
to find the simplest possible model that
can explain something or that works then
again it kind of motivates why you might
want to study this because this is
really the simplest thing you can can
imagine
so
um
what is our our main result here so the
main result is that in some sense if the
degree sequence is not nearly regular
then we can distinguish them in a very
strong sense that I can give you a
certain statistic that you can compute
for each of these that you can compute
and depending on which model you are
with high probability they will be in
different ranges so you can actually
tell just by looking at a specific
statistic which model
um the graph actually came from
so now what does um not nearly regular
mean here so the cartoon version is like
no no degree appears more than 99 of the
times of course you should really think
of this as one minus Epsilon fraction of
the time
um
so that shows in some sense that this
this degree restricted process does
deviate uh quite significantly from the
uniform distribution
so
you might ask yourself now okay
um what kind of statistic would you
would you look at here
use the microphone
I don't understand your definition of
not Daily Record because it it
this sort of suppose that would all be
equal
and then then that does not say no
degree appears
so if it's a regular then it would
appear 100 of the time and I want to
rule that out so I want to rule out that
one degree appears like 99 of the time
like one minus Epsilon fraction of the
time okay okay sorry
terrible
and is it should we understand that uh
the DN is forcing your graph to be not
regular or something
so this is our assumption here that um
if we look at any such degree sequence
it's not regular then this conclusion of
course so that's our assumption so we
don't make a statement in particular
about regular degree sequences here
I understand but just by choosing a
sequence we not really regular you're
forcing the graph to be not regular is
that how yes
is a regular image
yes
the integral half of the degrees can be
two half of the degrees can be one
that's right okay
so
um let me just tell you how the
statistic looks like if say you have a
reasonable amount of vertices of degree
one okay so imagine now your degree one
vertices are somewhere between one
percent and 99 and you should really
think of it as at least Epsilon n at
almost one minus Epsilon n then the edge
statistic that we're going to look at it
turns out it's enough to look at the
number of 1 1 edges so by one one edges
we mean edges where both endpoints have
degree one okay and so if you look at
this surprisingly simple statistic what
turns out that um they actually differ
in these two models and one thing I just
want to remark is that in some sense
this reinforces this idea that the
degree sequence of a graph is not
everything because this really shows the
fact that we generated this Graphics
degree process using this Evolution
using this process by adding edges one
at a time we do get other structural
properties so just saying the degree
distribution captures everything is a
big oversimplification in here it's a
very simple example which tells you that
some really Key Properties can change
just by the way you generate the graph
okay so
um that's one interesting point I want
to mention
and the other point I want to mention
here is that when you when you try to
prove such statements another kind of
difficulty is how to get the foot into
the door uh in some of these uh these
questions because I mean here we have a
uniform random graph and we have another
configuration model underlying there and
so there we really understand extremely
well what's going on in part because
this configuration model for generating
this random graphs as a given degree
sequence has these nice properties which
you can think of as like some form of
exchangeability you can kind of open up
the graph from
uh kind of any any point where you want
um and the order in which you look at
things does not matter but if you look
at this uh this process this is like a
very different story because kind of the
process has inherently some time
Evolution that's moving the process
forward so if you just want to even
understand how does locally some some
neighborhood look like it's quite a
complicated thing to analyze
and
um I in the boot camp there was
mentioned one technique how to
potentially study such processes you can
for example track the number of one one
edges at each step in the process for
example using the so-called differential
equation method which would give you a
prediction of how many one-on-one edges
there are in terms of the solution to
some differential equation okay
and this is one possible way one can try
to prove such results on this level of
generality and in particular if you give
me a particular degree sequence I can
put it in the computer and then confirm
yes it indeed differs from the
configuration model but I don't know how
to implement this argument in general
like how to control these differential
equations enough to make such a
statement so
um that's kind of still one open problem
in this background and that's why we use
the different technique which I think is
not used so much in the context or maybe
I don't know of an example actually
where it has been applied previously to
a stochastic process that is not uniform
so the method we're going to use is the
so-called switching method
which has been quite successful in
analyzing particular random
graphs with a given degree sequence
where these degrees are very high
because then you can no longer do this
trick of the configuration model that
you the condition on the configuration
well being simple because the
probability that the creation model is
simple is just tiny
are there more questions about the model
or the kind of result we're shooting at
yeah
like
I can remember
so I just want to check with my
intuition it's correct so I would assume
that the end process results in more
than one edges when they're truly
uniform random DN graph okay I'll show
um I think of the next slide actually
one reason why this might be true
sorry and the question was like um does
the guess was he was guessing that maybe
this process generates more 1-1 edges
than the uniform uh random graph and
what I said was that basically this was
something I wanted to discuss in the
next slide maybe one intuition why this
might be true it's not the way we prove
it but somewhere you might might think
of it so we discovered this originally
by doing this differential equation
approach but
so here's one way sort of a cartoon what
how you can think about this okay so
here let's just work with the
configuration model I mean we're working
here with degree sequences of bounded
maximum degrees so we can just as well
think of the configuration model
and now the way I like to think of the
configuration model for each vertex if
you have like can have degree three you
have kind of these three I don't know
either can call dangling edges stubs or
I guess everyone has their own favorite
terms for this and
um if you now run this sort of dynamic
version of the configuration model then
each step you connect two of these
dangling edges uniformly at random from
all possible choices okay now you can
check so how many ways are there to
connect for example this one one
um these two versions of degree one down
here there's one possible way right but
up here if I look at for example this
these three there are nine possible ways
to connect up here right so so
connecting these two vertices in one
step is much more likely than this one
down here okay so you have some kind of
preferential attachment mechanism
sitting here in the background with
respect to your unused degree okay but
if you now look at this DN process the
DN process has like a different
mechanism that drives this thing right
because remember how is it defined you
just add any possible edge here to the
graph this does not violate the degree
constraint okay and so what that means
is that the probability of adding this
edge here versus the probability of
adding this edge here is actually the
same in one step
so
um this simulate tells you that at least
in one step here the probability of
adding this Edge down here is much more
likely in the DN process compared to the
configuration model but note that this
is really just we're just looking at one
step here this is not yet say anything
about if we do do multiple steps but I
think it does Drive the point home that
here we have something uniform that's
working into something preferential so
it's plausible here that we actually do
get more of these
so what is the kind of result
that we uh that we prove so we already
said we're looking at these one one
edges of edges where both endpoints have
degree one and this this example where
we have lots and lots of degree one
vertices
and so in this case what we show
is that basically these two random
variables depending on which graph model
you look at Living disjoint intervals
with high probability actually with
exponentially small error probabilities
okay so we show that his G subscript D
and this is the uniform graph that lies
here in the middle that's concentrated
around this expected value and there are
many ways to prove it you can prove it
using first and second moment method or
you can prove it using that Sumo
heffielding inequality or you name it
your favorite method so that's the
standard part of the argument to show
some people fresh model that's that's
vanilla
argument and so the the key question is
how to show that the other process lies
somewhere else how can we how can we get
our our hands on that
and there I said in principle one can
try to use this this differential
equation technology but they're seeing
we don't have enough control over these
differential equations so in some sense
um might be
um weird on First Sight because you
reduce it to analytic problem we just
don't know how to solve the analytic
problem so we need something something
else
right
yes it's the same so I mean that
um
so the question was if the question was
by x11g you mean number of isolated as
ages yes so the point here this will
have degree one this will be have to be
one if you but if you look at more
General
um degree sequences then
um it's not just isolate it is going to
look at more complicated things it's
just this particular case where you have
many one vertices of degree one where
this works
foreign
how the general thing looks like but
this is a little bit easier to explain
what's going on
yes that's right so here we assume
always that the the maximum degree is
some some constant so
um yeah we did not try to optimize too
much for that
like so maybe you can allow some small
power Vlog I'm not sure
so
let me try to give you some glimpse of
what this this switching uh does okay so
so
um the whole point is somehow you want
to change your perspective so so why has
this method been very successful for
analyzing for example uniform random
graphs in regimes where the
configuration model does not work okay
so
um let me see if I can put it here so if
you think of some classical
um switching argument
um
how would that look like you would for
example try to understand
um how how does the probability that
your uniform random graph
generate
um so sorry this is one one I think here
so if I compare the probability that
this is equal to l
versus the probability
that this is
um
equal to to L plus one in the uniform
case the nice thing that happens is that
the renormalizing factor kind of cancels
out because we have a uniform
distribution so the total size of the
universe that you buy through that that
kind of just goes away right because
this here is just the number
of these say DN graphs so this I mean
the number of graphs with the degree
sequence TN
such that X11
is L
divided here by
so so this is now this this kind of in
the uniform setting looking at ratios
reduces yourself to accounting problem
and then you have to figure out
um by some by the switching taking which
I'll just mention a little bit about
what this ratio actually is okay so the
key point is it bypasses the need to
understand how many graphs your your
sample space actually has okay so so
that's for example a problem for D
regular graphs that was only solved a
few years ago how many deregular graphs
they are for all possible a d between
like 1 and n and so so this kind of
really bypasses this this technical
difficulty that this number is difficult
to understand
and here we want to apply
um a similar idea in the context of this
this stochastic process but now of
course
um the the process we're looking at is
not uniform okay so the simple uh
canceling out that happened in the
uniform model we cannot expect that to
happen so we have to implement this idea
slightly uh differently
pocket
so what underlies this this kind of
Technology it's it's
um this definition here which I just
give by example okay so the idea is the
following I give you some graph
I give you some graph and you identify
some very particular configurations so
here you identify here two vertices of
degree one which are connected to a
vertex of degree at least two
okay so this is like a version to be one
connects to vertex of degree two
and now you do some kind of local
perturbation operation which I think
there are also some similar ideas in the
context of Stein Shen method so what you
do is you replace these two edges just
by by these two edges okay so you go
from a situation where the graph stays
the same except as these edges get
deleted and these guys get inserted okay
so you just keep everything the same
except for these few edges
and now you want to understand how does
this local perturbation what effect does
it have on your probabilities
and the key Point here
is that in this in this graph here on
the right you have one one Edge more
than on the left but everything else
stays the same so the degree sequence
stays the same it's just that with
respect to our key statistic the number
of one one edges this graph has one one
Edge more
so so that's the thing we want to
understand in particular what is this
ratio now what is the ratio between have
seeing this graph and this graph okay
note that in the uniform model this
would just be one this would just be the
same but we're trying to find this slide
bias but we want to prove is that this
graph is a little bit more likely than
this one if we can show something like
this then we're in a very good shape of
proving actually that this process
really prefers these one one edges
and so um
as I already mentioned this this
classical idea of looking at these
probabilities and then you the the
normalizing factor cancels out we cannot
quite use that here so we have to look a
little bit
um more carefully into what's going on
and so what what we do
is I mean you first observe okay this
this thing that you get here is no
longer uniform or that's what we believe
um and in particular when you look at
what's the probability of getting one of
these graphs actually what happens is
you um there are very many different
trajectories of the process that can
give you this graph because kind of the
order in which you insert these edges
matters remember at the beginning I
showed this example that certain points
in time certain vertices become kind of
like inactive they're kind of their
degree is filled up and so these moments
when this happens really influences the
probabilities in your process so
depending on which order you look at the
edges you get different probabilities
so kind of what we do or what the idea
is now let's just look at it kind of one
step even deeper into the process we
kind of look on the level of
trajectories of these Edge sequences and
now try to to mimic this idea here that
that comes from the classical switching
method
so I don't quite see why in the uniform
model that would be the same because if
the probability of having l11 edges is
the same as having add plus one l11
address and the probability of an
infinite upon one edges is the same as
having zero okay so what I was referring
to is that the probability that you see
this graph and the product you see this
graph they will be the same I see but
you haven't explained how to calculate
this ratio no this will come on the next
even for uniform okay I I will mention
later on basically how how you also do
this for for uniform but the basic idea
is again you use this switching
operation and you ask yourself how many
ways are there to go from here to here
because you can kind of imagine you do
some switching to take a graph with L to
a graph with L plus one and you didn't
have to calculate how many ways is it
for one graph to go from here to here
and the other way around and if you
understand what these ratios are and
some nice things happen you can actually
out of that squeeze these probability
bounds
okay so the next slide
um might look a little bit scary on
first sight so but let me
oh no this is okay two slides away so
this one is still fine
um so
um so this is the the key Lemma that I
mean by by switching that we really want
to prove we want to prove we the the
degree restricted process favors this
graph over this one and the reason being
this graph has one one more Edge more
than the graph on the left okay that's
our goal and so the thing that turns out
to be tractable initially it looks a
little bit as if you have no chance but
we just expand out this probability that
you get a certain graph over all
possible Edge sequences that can give
you this graph so it's a gigantic sum
okay it's a gigantic sum and then our
goal was later to understand what
happens when we perturbate these guys
here
and um
it turns out to be surprisingly
tractable in this context I must say it
was really um
very nice
and so now this is the picture I alluded
to uh
so let me try to explain what what's
going on here okay so beforehand I said
we want to compare
um with what probabilities do certain
graphs appear
and now we want to kind of compare with
what probabilities to certain Edge
sequences appear
so so imagine I have some Edge sequence
Sigma which tells you exactly in which
order the edges of a certain graph
in which they arrive
and so what we're going to do is for
some technical reasons we have to pair
up two things we compare the probability
of certain two Edge sequences appear
with two other Edge sequences and now
the question is what are these Edge
sequences and what does it mean okay
and so recall that we did this switching
operation up here which says that
replace these two blue edges by these
two red edges okay and so now suppose
that we know certain points in time
where these edges a b and X Y where they
occur okay so to make everything
symmetric
um so okay first of all I say let's just
really fix these times here okay for the
moment and I mean for similar reasons
you should consider when AP occurs first
in X Y second or the other way around
where X Y appears first in a b second
and then you kind of exactly want to do
this switching operation now you want to
put exactly at these spots the edges
from your switching so you want to
replace a b x y by a x b y
okay and again you have both options one
Edge comes before the other one or the
other way around
so
if you fix the positions where these two
edges should appear these are kind of
all possibilities to complete this
switching picture up there
and
the main point is that actually if you
write all these things down as ratios
you can actually prove an inequality of
this form that the left hand side which
corresponds to these Edge sequences to
this guy is actually more likely than
the right hand side which corresponds to
Edge sequences from from here okay and
I'm not not hiding anything this is a
real inequality there's no little of one
there's no episode ever this is just an
equal that's always true
okay and the other advantages you prove
this by looking at at ratios
this way we don't really have to
calculate the full probability that you
see a certain trajectory which is
actually quite hard
um moreover the thing that I want to
mention here mainly this is still
consistent with our heuristic because
remember this blue guy here has one one
Edge more than the red one and the
inequality is going the right direction
because these two sequences correspond
to this graph over here okay so so far
everything is kind of consistent with
what's going on
but the main point I want to mention
bring across here is that there is a way
to to take these ideas from the
switching method and try to think of
them in terms of what does it mean in
terms of trajectories of your your
process when you go kind of one level
down
of course this is not yet enough because
we want to really show that this is
really more likely we need a little bit
of a boost but um
this is kind of the main idea
performance questions
okay so so once you have this uh
um this inequality for these Edge
sequences now it's it's kind of a matter
of putting things together because
remember when we we look at what's the
probability of getting a certain graph
you can sum over all possible Edge
sequences you regroup them in a suitable
way that you can apply this inequality
from the previous slide that we
established
um and that allows you directly to
compare the probability of getting one
graph with the probability of getting
the other graph
just expand things out regroup them in a
play each time they seem equal of course
there's not does not yet prove really
what we want right because we want this
guy is really more likely and the trick
is that
um we cannot prove that for each of
these Edge sequences there's a
difference but you can prove that in
this super large sum there are many
terms where you win a little bit and
that's enough to give you this extra one
plus Epsilon boost that we need to show
that this guy is really more likely than
the other one
all right so so now comes the part which
is more similar to classical uh
switching which which you asked about
how how this uh works and so here what
you do is you set up some auxiliary
Piper type graph you put just up here
all graphs where the number of these 11
edges is L plus one and down here where
all of them is l
and then what you do is you connect two
of these points which each correspond to
graphs if there's a way to do switching
from one to another okay this defines
you some nice Piper type graph and the
key point
is this really happens in all these
applications also when you study random
graphs as a given degree sequence is
here that in a certain regime these this
auxiliary bipartite graph will be
approximately regular in the sense that
all the degrees up here are roughly the
same and all of them down here are the
same but I mean the degree up here and
down here can be different but all of
them are kind of the same
and that means that if you have in such
a situation you can lift an inequality
from one graph to a class of graphs that
you're comparing here right before and
we just had it inequality one graph in
here is more likely than it's switching
partner down here but because this
auxiliary structure here is is um is so
regular you can actually lift it now to
this class of graphs
a kind of a double or weighted double
counting argument which underlies this
this kind of argument again the point is
we never need to calculate what is
actually the probability of any
trajectory we always look at ratios
um
so once you have this for
um for these classes of graphs
um yeah
it's just a matter of finishing off uh
by some careful arguments basically our
goal was to show that you're not very
close to this this movie which is the
expected number in the concreation model
now the idea is to to kind of look at
some telescoping products so you each
time compare uh what is the probability
of seeing um deviating Zed from the the
mean versus Z plus one from the mean and
if in each time you gain actually some
Factor one plus Epsilon then because
here you're deviating so much from the
means Epsilon mu which is kind of linear
and N you actually can show that the
probability of Landing close to the
expected value in the configuration
model is Super Chinese exponentially
small actually in this model
um but um
I know these arguments are are a little
technical but the main point is once you
have it on the on the level of graph
sequences or
um tragic choice of the process you can
lift it sequentially to the properties
we're interested in okay and and and
that's something that that we found very
interesting because we have not seen any
examples of the switching method applied
to stochastic uh processes and so I
think there's a lot of potential there
to to to use that
so some of you might now rightfully ask
so what about the more General case this
was just for one one yes
yes so I this argument here was just for
um for Simplicity I proved that you're
not in the middle oh sorry the the
question was that um uh whether you can
really prove that this process is here
on the on the right okay and the answer
is yes
um it just turns out that the argument I
showed you here does not work in general
you need a little bit of extra because
this comparison argument that this
auxiliary graph is bipartite so regular
only works when you're very close to the
expected value in the configuration
model so and even in a little different
argument but it's actually much simpler
to show that it cannot be too small
turns out
yes
so what are you going to show us the
thing about how taking this elimination
I'm sorry
so
the the the the
individual switching argument
I take it that that's because the two
vertical edges or sorry no the the the
horizontal edges
eliminate more edges that are allowed by
the degree by the degree sequence than
the two vertical edges do
or at least and so that there are with
fewer loud edges you're more likely to
get the other horizontal Edge or
something I so you're referring to this
this yeah yeah so okay so the story is
actually this inequality is not true if
you go to if you don't look at one one
edges so
well okay but I mean just this example
oh yeah yeah so that's true because once
you put down this this thing of one but
then you're kind of done you're you're
doomed this can no longer be chosen so
it turns out to be better if this
happens early on in in the process and
um
uh
yeah
I I would say that you know there are
certain heuristics that we had for this
case but all of them or the majority of
them all broke down when we go to more
General case so it's a little hard to
reason about about the case where the
argument does not not generalize so it's
a little bit a little bit tricky so we
first thought all of this would go
through to the general case then my
student came up with some counter
example and then
so basically what happens is that also
when you allow for larger degrees also
what happens in your neighborhood
somehow starts mattering so quite tricky
what happens with these problems I wish
really there was a simple simple reason
how to reason about it
okay so let me just say that this
approach you can try the same so now we
need to find some replacement in the
general case what does it mean what's
the replacement for one one
um Edge and so here you you say there's
a Vertex is called small if the degree
is at mode s and what you want is that
there's a reasonable amount of small
edges again between say one percent and
99 percent and now you want to count how
many small edges are there in this
process and again you want to prove that
the number of these small edges is
different so the process generates and
what the random guy generates okay so
again you see the how you arrive at the
graph matters
and as I already alluded to
unfortunately some of these key
inequalities fail so I mean what was
underlying our our heuristic that this
graph with more 1 1 edges should be
um
uh that if you do some kind of a
switching then you you win okay so here
in this in this case here um
uh
here this is you would look at kind of
this this point here so this corresponds
here to vertex of three two and this
corresponds to vertex of degree two
um so that would be a small here because
we have vertices of degree three and we
when we do the switching of this guy
here compared to
um with this vertex down here then uh
what happens is that this graph is um
actually less likely than this one so it
kind of goes it's not just fails a
little bit it fails completely right we
want to prove it's at least one plus
Epsilon and it's actually only 0.82
okay so so this idea of looking at
graphs no longer no longer works and so
this example was kind of surprising
because it's ruined all the the
intuition it goes up beforehand but
there there's a way around and I I will
not go into details how this works too
much but the idea is instead of focusing
just on graphs you find some clever way
how to regroup the graphs so if you look
at graphs in one group and compare them
with graphs in the other group the
inequality still works in the correct
direction okay so it's kind of like you
instead of doing this this switching
idea on individual graphs you would on
groups of graphs which are very
carefully chosen to make this argument
work
okay
that's maybe what I want to
um to say about that
so let me maybe otherwise
summarize
um so we looked at this degree
restricted uh process where we started
off with an empty graph on on N vertices
and each step we kind of put down a
random Edge without violating this
degree constraint
and then the main question was is this
similar to uniform random graph or not
and the main story was that if the
grease sequence is not nearly regular so
if no vertex appears more than 99 of the
time then we can actually distinguish
these two graphs in a very strong way I
give you an explicit Edge statistic that
you can calculate in polynomial time and
based on that you will be able to say
with high probability does it come from
this graph or this graph in fact
what our argument also shows let me just
mention that is that if you look at the
total variation distance between these
two guys
so um we had once the the process and
once the uniform graph
um what we can show is that the total
variation distance is extremely close to
one in this case so it's actually
exponentially close
to one so it's really really nearly
maximal
um and also argument shows that you know
you if you want to go from the graph
that is generated by this process to the
graph generated by the uniform graph you
actually need to change at least a
linear number of edges so they're really
really far apart in in terms of how to
go from a one to another
so what was the interesting one
interesting thing here I think one
interesting thing was the proof
technique that we used because this idea
of using the switching technique to
analyze stochastic processes that that
was kind of a new idea and I hope that
this has some more uh potential
and I do want to mention in terms of
open problems I do believe that when you
look at regular degree sequences I do
believe that these two are same so I'm
kind of with warm out there on the same
page that
somehow it feels that they they're
really so close whatever you at least
what we try to look at and so on it's
really hard to to have any idea what's
going on how could they be different so
that's
um I really think would be interesting
problem how to show that actually these
are contiguous they are similar for
regular degree sequences and I do want
to mention that I particularly believe
the two regular case has has some
potential for for maybe one can do
something so note that for two regular
case you're just looking at the
collection of Cycles yes so it's like as
simple as it can get so there should be
some way how to to prove things
um and the the closest maybe to show
some similarity like really close
similarity between these models is that
we know of with respect to the giant
component Behavior so if you look at for
example the um
two regular case when you look at this
um this process
plus the uniform one so let me see um
two regulars say
process
as uniform they have the same behavior
in the following sense that if you look
at the two regular a random graph you do
not have a concentrated giant component
so it's a little bit different than the
classical Theory so so what the result
looks like there you get is that the
size of the largest component and so
here you can put in either of these two
things either the process which
generates it or the uniform one and you
look at what's the probability that this
has at least size c times n then in both
models it converges to the same function
f of C where this function effort
between 0 1. so this is the I would say
the closest thing that we know where
these two models behave very very
similar okay but
um we're still the arguments we use here
are still not fine enough to prove
anything like contiguity or total
variation distance or anything like that
okay so you still have a little wiggle
room
um because of the error term and so on
and so forth but I do think that this is
some further supporting evidence that
most likely it's actually true for these
uh
two regular degree sequences so I think
that would be a really nice uh problem
to show that the stimuli or I would be
really surprised if they're different
maybe that would be even more
interesting
foreign I mean locally you will just see
like some some tree right at the end
it's a deregular tree so so so you need
some kind of more Global statistics but
um
I don't know if you really want to
distinguish them how that would look
like
that's kind of the the question like
what's statistic to look at and how to
actually prove at the difference for
example you might look at the
eigenvalues and so on but then maybe
becomes a little tricky how do you
calculate
um
yourself
okay
I'll open up just for more questions
hey do you have more questions
of course your final example here raises
the question whether the giant is
different in the degree the degree
irregular cases right I mean you can
prove that the two laws are very
different but are the sizes of the giant
also very different so you would believe
so but
foreign
if you go to larger degrees then they're
they're connected at the end right so
it's kind of a
slightly different story
um what I can tell you is you can see
but he didn't meet sorry but he didn't
mean decree at least three he meant that
you have some degree distribution but
it's the lowest degrees to two let's say
yes okay
um
we have studied this giant component
question but not necessarily at the end
so we kind of studied the giant
component for now when it actually
happens when it starts emerging and it
happens that um
for the interesting case it happens
before the end so you you see the giant
already emerging before the end and
there what I know based on on
simulations is that
um the uh the distribution that you get
seems to differ from the configuration
model so what we did is the following so
we we kept track of the degree sequence
of the process at any point in time and
then we plug that into model I read and
so you can kind of ask well I read when
would I read tell me that there's a
giant and then you can ask when does it
actually happen in this in this process
and they happen at different times so
it's kind of a strong indication that
early on
um these two guys are different but that
still does not belong to the end they
still have the same distribution
I wish someone can prove that they're
different I think it would be really
interesting
other questions
okay who is the next speaker